karl lauterbach
bundesgesundheitsminister er sollte
entführt werden von terroristen
militanten gegnern seiner corona politik
offenbar von radikalen aus der
querdenker szene was für eine nachricht
an diesem donnerstag vor ostern die
ermittler sie sind diese entführung von
karl lauterbach zuvorgekommen operation
klabautermann so haben diese terroristen
das genannt ihren plan der jetzt
aufgeflogen ist und die pläne dieser
terroristen die sich vereinte patrioten
nennen die waren offenbar schon sehr
weit fortgeschritten wie es heißt 12.000
euro hatten sie schon gesammelt um
waffen zu kaufen
kalaschnikows 12 sturmgewehre sollen bei
ihm gefunden worden seien pistolen und
auch wien hatten sie besorgt das haben
die ermittler in rheinland-pfalz aber
jetzt gestoppt es gab vier festnahmen
und zwölf frauen und männer standen im
visier der ermittler und jetzt eben hat
sie karl lauterbach gegenüber bild
geäußert dazu mit diesen sätzen schauen
wir einmal drauf auf das erste statement
uns gegenüber von ihm vom
bundesgesundheitsminister er sagt
manchen corona leuten geht es nicht um
den kampf gegen impfungen oder corona
auflagen sie kämpfen gegen unsere
demokratische grundordnung damit werden
sie aber keinen erfolg haben ich lasse
mich dadurch nicht beirren sondern setze
mich weiter für die gesamte für die
gesamte bevölkerung ein sagt karl
lauterbach und zugeschaltet jetzt
angelika hellemann mit der wir über
diese sätze von karl lauterbach sprechen
wollen aber vor allen dingen über diese
operation klabautermann wie diese
terroristen das genannt haben eine
geplante entführung vom
bundesgesundheitsminister ich grüße dich
herzlich bild chefreporterin angelika
hellemann
also das sind ja erschreckende pläne die
dort ja glücklicherweise rechtzeitig
aufgeflogen sind die tatsächlich sehr
konkret war nach allen informationen die
wir mittlerweile haben angelika ja die
dänen waren tatsächlich sehr konkret und
sie wurden noch von den
sicherheitsbehörden extrem ernst
genommen karl lauterbach ag eine sehr
hohe sicherheitsstufe das heißt er wird
eigentlich ständig beschützt es sind
immer personenschützer um ihn herum aber
durch diese gefahr jetzt was er
tatsächlich entführt werden sollte und
dass es sich nicht um eine abstrakte
gefahr sondern um einen ganz konkreten
plan hals hielt deswegen wurden dann
zivilschützer in sein umfeld gepackt das
heißt um ihn herum waren immer etliche
leute die man überhaupt nicht als
personenschützer erkennen konnten und
die dann ebenfalls diese gruppe doch
zugeschlagen hätte einen hätten
eingreifen können die behörden hatten
diese operation klabautermann
offensichtlich schon länger im visier
warum haben sie so lange abgewartet
warum haben sie es jetzt zugeschlagen
das machen die ja ganz oft weil sie
müssen ja tatsächlich dann auch
handfeste beweise haben und deswegen ist
es ja so die bahn dann ja waffen gekauft
aber sie haben diese waffen dann
glücklicherweise für die gesellschaft
bei den ermittlern selbst gekauft das
heißt solche leute werden dann eben auch
gezielt in fallen gelockt damit man
ihnen dann auch habhaft werden kann und
damit man dann eben auch die
strippenzieher tatsächlich vor gericht
stellen kann wir sehen hier werden wir
mit dir sprechen ein video dass karl
lauterbach selbst geteilt hat in diesen
tagen anfang der woche dass es so
schreibt er es in diesem tweet von
anfang der woche vor seinem haus
entstanden der film offenbar er selbst
eine gruppe von querdenkern die da
vorbeizieht bei ihm in köln und dazu
schreibt der vor meiner wohnung
protestieren die impfgegner die proteste
radikalisieren sich möglicherweise
wusste er zu diesem zeitpunkt schon von
noch konkreteren bedrohung denn die
spricht er selber an sie seien diese
gewaltdrohung leider auch alltag gegen
ihn persönlich angelika das hat er
anfang der woche geschrieben was weißt
du selbst über die bedrohung und vor
allen dingen darüber wie er damit selber
umgegangen ist wie er das selber
empfunden hatte in den vergangenen
monaten jahren muss man mittlerweile
sagen
tatsächlich wusste karl lauterbach von
dieser gruppe da wird er immer
informiert und an politiker der so
konkret bedroht wird oder bei dem sich
die lage so ändert der bekommt das dann
auch mit und es wird ihm mitgeteilt es
muss auch so sein weil er sich ja dann
dementsprechend auch verhalten muss und
karl lauterbach selbst lässt glaube ich
eigentlich wenig erschüttern er selbst
sagt auch für sich dass er nicht
besonders viel angst hat aber karl
lauterbach ist fünffacher familienvater
und dann ist es natürlich extrem
belastend vor allen dingen weil ja seine
kinder das jetzt auch erfahren also so
lange so eine operation läuft gibt es
halt strengster geheimhaltung da wissen
dass immer nur die allerwenigsten person
also karl lauterbach sein engstes umfeld
im beruf und so also die die es wissen
müssen aber das soll halt nicht nach
außen bringen damit man dann eben den
schlag gegen solche terroristen nicht
vermasselt aber für ihn ist es halt sehr
schlimm wenn seine kinder das jetzt
lesen müssen dass papa entführt werden
sollte weil das macht natürlich angst
diese kriminelle vereinigung hatte noch
weitere pläne sie wollten nicht nur karl
lauterbach entführen sondern hatten auch
noch geplante bundesweit einen längeren
stromausfall herbeizuführen der denn für
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände in
deutschland hier sorgen sollte was weißt
du darüber ja das war eben tatsächlich
hat es so war es am zweifach plan einmal
ein bundesminister entführen und
gefangen halten und dann tatsächlich die
stromversorgung kappen weil jeder weiß
dass wenn der strom weg ist gibt es sehr
schnell ja
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände fangen
plündereien an und so wollte die gruppe
einen umsturz machen also denen geht es
tatsächlich nur indirekt und die korona
maßnahmen eigentlich geht es ihnen darum
die demokratie zu beseitigen danke für
den moment bild reporterin angelika
hellemann an diesem tag an dem rauskommt
karl lauterbach sollte entführt werden
von einer kriminellen ja terroristischen
vereinigung offenbar dort in rheinland
pfalz die staatsanwaltschaft koblenz hat
diesen fall übernommen auch die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft ermittelt in
diesem fall karl lauterbach sollte
entführt werden von radikalen gegnern
seiner corona politik